bang-bang everyone what's going on time
for lunch money while Wall Street trying
to get rich the rest of us just trying
to get a lunch money right I'm here with
the beautiful clean Amer Nova she traded
in the guns for a first-year analysts
outfit looks like she's got the Midtown
uniform on ready to go to her investment
banking job you got a joke are you gonna
start finding out for the joke let's get
into Amos dams don't kind of look like
Jeff Bezos and not you know that picture
if he looks like The Terminator and you
wring this vest
it kind of look like that you should
shake your head and maybe you know you'd
be good to go I what is Bezos land doing
so basically calling yesterday and Bezos
said if you're shareholder or share
owner in Amazon you may want to take up
bags take a seat take a seat I really
messed that quote you did it's okay so
everyone knows everyone's pay attention
to Amazon earnings report yesterday
obviously there's lots of businesses
that are suffering but Amazon of all
businesses they make up like almost 50
percent of e-commerce sales they've been
doing very very well lots of sales
online because people have to order
things and so really their challenges
have been a little just excited a make
sure that their employees are safe how
do they get packages whether they need
to be right and when all the world is
basically ordering on Amazon the bad
news was they basically said if we
continued as we can are continuing we
would make four billion dollars in
profit in q2
so April May and June of this year
they'd make four billion dollars but we
are not going to make that profit
because we're gonna spend all four
billion dollars on kovat 19 related
activities so they're gonna spend this
entire year about a billion dollars just
on testing for their employees to make
sure everyone's safe they haven't do a
lot of things on logistical front and so
you know my whole take away is just
Amazon's a cockroach company but they
went years and years and years this
cockroach so the whole idea of being a
cockroach is like you do whatever it
takes to survive
and for years nobody likes you well
people still might like you or they
might not like you but right now like a
lot of early-stage startups they've got
to be careful you just can't run out of
money rule number one a business don't
run out of money is you got to be this
cockroach you do whatever it takes to
not run many Amazon's not in you know
anywhere near running out of money but
what they are doing or what they have
done for years and years is they operate
a super thin margins so they would post
no profit for years and years and years
and shareholders would like is this
company ever gonna make a profit but
what he was doing was he was driving a
bunch of money taking it and reinvesting
it in the business that's essentially
what he's doing here so look people are
gonna be upset because it's not gonna
make you know four billion dollars in in
profits this year or in this quarter but
but all these people this show is about
the little guy right the little guy yeah
are you anti Amazon so let me just tell
you something I'm not anti Amazon well
we know because I see the orders you
order from Amazon like Bailey go ahead
basically I have source a good source
that is a small business owner that
works if Amazon do you not say who it is
dad has told me that right now I don't
know why but like as a small business
owner basically what you do is you send
your product to Amazon to its
fulfillment centers and then from there
Amazon's like logistical process kicks
in and they can ship your pre send it
before you sold it right so they always
have like a small inventory of your
stuff I knew that you're like a private
equity analyst in the making small
inventory and then when somebody orders
it they can ship it in from Tennessee or
wherever it is do they use American
Airlines AAA for life so that was a
dramatic pause so what happened was
apparently because I don't know if
people aren't working I don't know if
there's like what's going on if their
process is a little messed up right now
but people were ordering things and then
Amazon is not shipping them yeah it's a
logistical challenge right now out right
yeah of course they're trying to hire a
hundred thousand plus simple
right and there's a bunch of issues with
how did they actually process such high
volumes of waters like even them who
supposed to be the best in the world at
this there's still so much so many
learners coming in and then you also
have to keep all the employees safe as
well while you're doing this but here's
the problem if I'm a customer and I
order something and it does not come on
time I think most people are forgiving
but there of course those customers who
are unhappy 99% of the time so they go
and they leave a review on that small
business page and say this didn't come
when it showed up whatever it is not the
small businesses fault it is
Amazon's fault but then you get bad
reviews because of Amazon and then you
just go down and the algorithm so
obviously Amazon's not perfect right but
there could but there would be an
argument that says if you don't like
Amazon's process go sell somewhere else
which would take away most of the
revenue for a small business like that
so I agree with you that Amazon it needs
to fix that and I think that's what
they're basically saying here is they're
gonna make the investments to ensure
they fix that yeah fully vested make the
investment investment oh my god all
right what's going on with Carso love
story short Amazon is down in trading
they're not gonna make a profit in q2 of
this year they're really kind of taking
coronavirus seriously but as we've come
to find out Jeff Bezos runs the world
because there seems to be boxes showing
up at our apartment every single day to
the point where the gentleman downstairs
when we walk into our building literally
starts laughing and I asked Polina
I say Polina what did you order and she
will say something like I don't know I
forgot
Korona life that's gone on Crona life I
did not want to put this in here he made
me because I told you to be wary of
headlines that say according to a
scientist so we can tie scientists now
no but like there's so many random
predictions and I think if you're gonna
start paying attention to all though but
anyway some scientists from the
University of Minnesota have predicted
that the corona virus pandemic is likely
to last between 18 and 24 months what
does that mean
in what form so the reason I wanted to
put this in I just wanted to make fun of
the fact that this is ridiculous there
are scientists who are literally saying
the pandemic
last for two years but these people are
smoking crack
look that's literally what's going on
here this this is pure fear porn that's
what that is
you know yeah that term fear porn it
basically means all they want is they
want people to be fearful they want to
drive the narrative of like the world's
ending the pandemics gonna go on forever
the problem with this is these people
will never be held responsible what they
should do
here's what we should say to every
scientist if you're gonna make
predictions like this and you're gonna
drive that if you're wrong within some
order of magnitude if you're wrong you
should lose your job that's a little
extreme why what's the skin in the game
that they have and I and I either make
money or I lose money based on the
predictions I have skin in the game so
if I say X is gonna do Y and I'm wrong I
literally lose money well a scientist
whose sister says I wrote up this white
paper and this white paper says that the
pandemics gonna last for 24 more months
oh okay maybe but what the skin in the
game do they have if they're wrong so
that way I know how confident you are
and then because if you put like 50k
over Daniel they're very confident but
if you put like 50 bucks on me we give
up more on lunch money so basically what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
figure out what's their confidence level
and I'm exaggerating a little I don't
actually think that they should lose
their jobs if they're wrong because
science is hard predictions are hard but
I do think that the underlying sentiment
of just throwing out these wild
predictions to cause fear and chaos is
not helpful if you go back do you
remember the Imperial College study that
literally said like 6 million or 5
million people in the United States were
gonna die it scared the [ __ ] out of
everybody including the US government
into this lockdown and then lit within
like three weeks they came out oh we
were off taking a couple of zeros off
that number right and by the way it
doesn't mean that the virus isn't bad
it's just when you have such variety in
your predictions and there's so much
volatility and there's millions oh now
there's going to be a couple hundred
thousand people that die like a couple
hundred thousand still back it's just
you get desensitized to a couple hundred
thousand because you just heard five
million so one of my friends
I texted me some insane stuff like some
article about Crona virus and in under
normal circumstances that piece of news
would have been surprising and I was
like literally nothing surprising me
anymore it's unlike desensitized to
everything and I think that that's
exactly what this does if you're
somebody who spends the whole day on the
internet reading the news and you're
like oh my god 24 bucks like that can do
some serious damage to your psyche I
mean listen drink dropped an album last
night at midnight and you know Drake
don't miss a 20/20 has some things that
still go alright what's going on with
that revenue I she wouldn't let me put
that in the topic so I went ahead and
just slid right in there Drake's album
go downloaded 12 midnight last night
listen I listen to a low elite version
of it last night I was bobbing and
weaving in my sleep
go ahead and revenue what's going on go
ahead add revenue so big tech and AD
firms were relatively unscathed by
declining ad revenue in q1 but q2 is
looking ominous see how I changed that
out there it says outlook is darker I
don't even know what the word ominous
mean sounds like an SAT word so it's not
in my vocabulary but the whole idea here
is obviously people are spending bunch
of time online there are a lot of
platforms that are basically reporting
lower CPMs right so that costs for each
advertisement is going down but because
volumes are going up more people are
visiting websites and things like that
the net basis is pretty flat that's
basically what we saw so they didn't
make a ton of more money but they also
didn't lose as much money but on a CPM
basis which is cost per thousand views
for an ad that's gone down but it's made
up by just more people being on the
internet which it shouldn't surprise
anyone a lot about a lot of advertisers
have pulled back right so here's an
interesting little Ludd dichotomy which
is a word that I had to look up today I
knew the word I shouldn't have spell its
how to look it up with the DI CH ot oh
my yeah that's right that's right it
might be a SAT word actually might have
a bigger vocabulary than you realize so
the dichotomy is that a lot of smaller
advertisers are actually pulling back
because there
Erbs cockroach mode right how do I not
spend money so I don't increase my burn
rate but large advertisers who have
bigger budgets and have a lot of capital
they realized wait a second I can crush
my competition right now because CPM is
just went down so they'll actually spend
more and try to grab market share so is
this really weird kind of cat-and-mouse
game or some might say you know at the
Country Club a dichotomy all right
what's going on with ranked fluffy puppy
no it's we work and by the way if you
notice cockroach mode ends with you
still having a business we work modes
gonna end with that company going under
but keep going to rent rent rent is due
rent is due
okay okay so rent is due because it's
like the first of the month oh my god
can you believe it's me it's me
may one think that's a song so basically
it's been two months since coronavirus
kind of hit New York and now Friday is
May Day and for without work around 40%
of New Yorkers can't pay a single
month's rent so another there's a strike
whoa what one-third of people didn't pay
rent in April it was the reported number
yeah one third of renter's either didn't
pay or tried to get a reduction I think
was the actual stat so this my mean
landlords are gonna get demolished this
month these people have literally been
out of work for a month they haven't
received a paycheck in a month and maybe
they're getting so unemployment or
something like that remember 30 million
Americans in the last six weeks have
applied for uninsurance first time on
insurance benefits and so they just
don't have money for rent it's gonna be
really really bad so we'll see what
happens
applause anyway so people are calling
for a rent freeze and now the mayor of
New York City is calling for a rent
freeze for the first I don't think they
should do that
why not because you're gonna put too
much pressure on the landlords why
should the landlord suffer well then the
landlords are gonna start freaking out
and then it's just gonna go up the chain
but again
this is a very bad situation we
shouldn't make light of it but somebody
entered into a contractual agreement
okay but how are you supposed to pay you
have no income but again there's things
that you can go do so people are filing
for unemployment insurance etc but you
can't start to like that the fabric of
society breaks down when you start to
break down the trust that people have in
contractual agreements so you and I
enter into a contract and if I know that
all of a sudden if I can't hold up my
end of the contract I can just run to
the government and the government will
say oh you're fine it reduces all the
risk for me and it actually teaches me
to go do it over and over and over I
don't think this would fly under normal
circumstances but because we're in this
crazy period of time people are doing it
because they can't pay you can literally
walk into a bookstore put a blindfold on
and ask can I where is the personal
finance section and they'll have three
things in there have multiple streams of
income spend less than you make and make
sure you always have like six months of
cash every single book in the world has
told people that for like all of
eternity you will listen but if they
don't listen is that the landlords fault
is that the bank's fault or is that the
person's fault and by the way I actually
think what we're figuring out here is
people are going to get reminded you
have to be disciplined remember what I
said I don't know a single person right
now struggling that has multiple streams
of income or spends less than they make
and so the people who made the
disciplined hard decisions during the
good times are well positioned right now
the people who didn't do that stuff
they're the ones who are struggling we
should help them but you can't go so far
as to break down the fabric of society
about breaking contractual agreements
we'll see it's complex
what's going on with NASCAR not to be
confused with go ahead NASCAR announces
revised May schedule is racing returns
on Sunday May 17th because this is a
socially distant sport Robyn is racing
if you ain't first you're last
Ricky Bobby you know who that is
literally I'm shaking do you know who
Ricky Bobby is yeah I think his along
here yeah we actually know a NASCAR
driver Landon Cassill shoutout polenta's
been to dinner with
[Music]
so Landon told me actually though that
what they've been doing is they've been
doing virtual races like kinda like East
four style so you know basically like I
could just you know get a get a little
system and I could go enter into the
race and you know Danny Hamlin Landon
Cassill Jeff Gordon Dale Earnhardt jr.
whoever wants it I got you yes can I
tell my story one time yes we will only
have four minutes we got to get through
two more topics so for me when I was
like 15 or 14 my dad went to the NASCAR
like loop practice track no it was the
real track okay the track the channel
loop okay he got to drive a car like a
NASCAR how fast did he go very fast okay
you were very vested in that story but
yeah it was really cool like I got to
sit there and just like did you go I
went in the car no you drive I was just
the audience no it was so funny like you
see these like short little like fat men
and they just like kind of jump in there
through the window like real quick
you ever seen Dukes of Hazzard oh wait
no I think that's like the Millennial
version where they tried to make it cool
again Dukes of Hazzard is an old show
and they just run up the Duke boys that
run up and they get right into the car
yeah she wear short shorts but that's in
the new version that version sucks we'll
watch the old version and then you can
let us know what you think okay speaking
of cars machines what happened with the
ejection okay so this 64 year old man
his company had an outing to an airbase
and they were like you're gonna fly in a
fighter jet today he's like oh my god
I'm so not into this but he did it
anyway and his heart was like how potata
so fast SAT word okay so then he got so
nervous he grabbed something this sounds
like something I would do honestly it's
really scary he grabbed something and
accidentally pressed the edge
but in a panic and he tumbled through
the sky wait a 64 year old man ejecting
himself from a fighter jet while he was
doing it it's recreational yeah as he's
doing recreational activity please tell
me how to parachute how amazing look at
his recorded heart rate range from 136
to 142 beats per minute mine is like
literally 200 when I'm working out oh
yeah I might 142 if I walk up two
flights of stairs I'm like I died when
the jet was 2500 feet above ground the
pilot began to climb and passengers
pressed it oh the oh the pilot went
vertical you ever seen Top Gun you know
that movie with Tom Cruise and what can
one of the scenes he says he's going
vertical and so am I when they just go
to vertical that's what this guy that's
really scary is it remember how we
talked about the g-forces when you got
to go to space yeah and you just freaked
out and hit stuff honestly if it was me
I would probably have a heart attack in
the moment between pressing the button
being contracted this is the second I
realized I'm being injected I'm dead
like I'm out I feel like if you're over
the age of 60 why'd you start doing
crazy [ __ ] thank ya I mean on average I
think the average life expectancy United
States is 77 years old so you only got
17 years left like might as well just go
see what happens what time I was saying
something like something something when
were like 60 I told myself my entire
life I'm not gonna make it to 30 so I
just take crazy [ __ ] I made it at 30 I
was like wow that whole new life what's
up hey alright anything else for the
people alright we're giving away $100
again it's Friday that means it's lunch
money time so take the video take the
URL actually hold on before you take the
URL hit the like button smash the like
button as some people say make sure that
you are subscribed so that you can get
all these videos take the URL go tweet
it use the hashtag you don't use the
hashtag it doesn't count
use hashtag lunch money so we can find
it on Twitter so we had trouble with
that in the past use hashtag lunch money
and tell us your favorite joke from this
week take the URL tweeted its hashtag
lunch money tweet
whatever your favorite joke was this
week we'll pick one person you get a
hundred bucks lunch money can go to
dinner you can go spin on Amazon you go
buy Bitcoin you can do whatever the hell
you want with it
facts but that's it for this week we've
had a blast we have a surprise as well
Sunday 12:00 noon Eastern we're gonna be
doing a live Q&A make sure you tune in
on YouTube for the Q&A ask questions
there's a comment section that they
leave the comments on YouTube yep and
then you're gonna read it yeah that's
how YouTube works but like once for a
live not before yes yeah nice I don't
wanna you don't want a high-five but
instead you just give me the Mike Tyson
Sheila what alright guys that's it for
lunch money this week well while she's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get a lunch money right we
appreciate you watching I hope that you
enjoyed the analysis by my Wall Street
banker friend here and her vest and we
will see you guys on Sunday